[Music]
this is a CBS News special report
I'm Jeff Glor in New York North Korea is
trumpeting what it calls the country's
first intercontinental ballistic missile
test some scientists say the missile had
the potential to reach Alaska the u.s.
monitors say it flew for about 40
minutes reaching a height of 1,500 miles
and splashing down about 580 miles away
in the Sea of Japan it appears to be the
most successful test the North Korean
regime has ever carried out u.s. and
South Korean officials believe it was an
intermediate-range missile the North
Korean regime led by kim jeong-hoon
claims the missile marks the quote final
step in building a nuclear arsenal that
can strike anywhere on earth Ben Tracy
is in Beijing with reaction to this test
Ben good morning Jeff good morning here
in Beijing the Chinese government is
urging restraint but if North Korea's
claims are true when they have
successfully tested this ICBM well that
would be a game-changer in terms of the
North Korean threat now these are
pictures that were put out by North
Korean state television that show the
launch of the rocket they're calling the
Hasan 14 experts say they estimate it
has a range of about 4,000 miles which
would make it capable of hitting all of
Alaska but not the continental United
States or Hawaii the big question now is
whether North Korea has been able to
miniaturize a nuclear warhead to fit on
top of the missile North Korea has
conducted 11 missile tests this year
showing their growing capabilities now
in response President Trump tweeted that
he wants China to put a quote heavy move
on North Korea to end this nonsense once
and for all it is not clear what that
heavy move would actually be but it is
clear that the Chinese government is not
prepared to do it they came out here
today and they said that they want the
u.s. to talk to North Korea and they
don't want to either side to take any
action and further escalate the
situation Jeff all right don't race in
Beijing then thank you very much we'll
have much more on the North Korean
missile test coming up at 7:00 a.m. on
CBS this morning our coverage will
continue during the day and our 24-hour
streaming network
cbsn this has been a CBS News special
report
I'm Jeff Glor CBS News in New York we're
news 24 hours a day
go to CBS news.com